Про створення незалежної української православної церкви
говорять не один рік,
однак для цього Україна має зробити кілька важливих кроків.
Зазвичай, Томос, тобто документ, яким визнається
право церкви на незалежне управління,
надається вже автономним чи залежним церковним спільнотам,
які довели здатність бути самостійними.
В Україні діє декілька православних церков:
московського партіархату, київського партіархату,
а також автокефальна православна церква.
Щоб не надавати томос окремій церкві,
в Україні потрібно створити нову структуру.
Це може статися під час Об’єднавчого собору,
де зібралися би представники трьох вищезгаданих церков.
Після формування нової української церкви
мають обрати її першого предстоятеля.
Саме він мав би отримати томос про автокефалію
і став би "офіційним" Київським патріархом.
Найбільш ймовірним кандидатом на цю посаду
називають нинішнього очільника української православної
церкви Київського патріархату - Філарета.
Чи не найбільше за отримання українською церквою незалежності
борються у Київському патріархаті.
Саме він, як припускають експерти, і стане ядром
майбутньої церкви разом з автокефальною православною церквою.
У Київському патріархаті тим часом сподіваються,
що до нової структури долучатимуться також
і нинішні парафіяни та священики Московського патріархату.